In this section, we will touch upon different approaches for achieving likeness using the
MetaHuman Framework tools.
We will also address expectations regarding how far customizations to the neutral pose
can be pushed before encountering issues.
We can approach achieving likeness with MetaHuman characters using the various MetaHuman Framework
tools.
A good place to start is with the MetaHuman Creator.
Something to keep in mind is that the MetaHuman presets come from a database of real-world
scanned people.
This means the more faces that are added to the database, the larger the options will
be to achieve specific facial features.
Another option is to use the mesh to MetaHuman workflow.
The MetaHuman plugin allows users to create a MetaHuman identity from a mesh, from footage,
or from a template mesh.
The MetaHuman identity can be solved based on image or geometry.
With the DNA calibration tools, MetaHuman customizations can be pushed even further.
This workflow requires some knowledge in rigging, modeling, and Python.
Let's move on and address expectations for achieving likeness with our characters.
It is important to keep in mind the golden triangle of the face when making changes to
the neutral pose.
The triangle is related to the database that the MetaHuman presets come from.
Stylized faces with exaggerated facial features introduce large deltas outside of the database
range.
And this can result in issues with range of motion when animation is applied.
Here are a few considerations when working with stylized MetaHuman faces.
For cinematics, if using only LOD0, certain facial features can be pushed further, such
as a stronger jawline, bigger ears, a larger forehead, or a larger upper nose and cheekbones.
It is possible to see breaks in the golden triangle area of the face.
However, you can get away with a lot more when using only LOD0.
For games where LODs in optimization are crucial, it is likely to see issues with range of motion
with exaggerated facial features such as a big or tiny nose, lips, or eyes.
In addition, customizations to LOD0 will not be passed down to the lower LODs, as those
are joints only and require joint matching.
In cases like these, the mesh to MetaHuman workflow using the template mesh option may
help to transfer the larger shapes to the lower LODs.
However, there will still be more work to do.
And that is where DNA calibration comes in.
Now something to note about using a globally applied blend shape for customizations.
At first, it might appear that this can help achieve more likeness with the neutral pose.
But since the vertex and joint positions of the rig are not updated in the DNA file,
the face may not behave correctly when animations are applied, and that shape will not be present
for lower LODs.
Now that we have addressed expectations and considerations when working with stylized MetaHuman
faces, let's move on to the next portion of our course, where we explore a variety of
customization workflows that can be used to modify the MetaHuman neutral pose.